movie theatres bars nightclubs arenas
cafes they're all closed as the novel
coronavirus has been spreading around
the world and now quickly across the
United States more and more government
officials are calling for citizens to
implement social distancing an essential
mandate to slowing the spread of the
virus the entertainment industry has
never faced anything like this before
movie theaters have never really closed
down on such a large scale and the box
office is already suffering after just
two weeks things are gonna get a lot
worse but these might be temporary
solutions for huge long-lasting problems
if these measures to slow coronavirus
stay in place until July as president
Trump signaled this could mean a loss of
12 billion dollars for the entertainment
industry you've got to think about a
broader spectrum of the economy of the
entertainment industry for example when
a movie is being released
if it's certainly if it's a larger movie
millions of dollars have spent in
advance promoting that movie some of the
larger titles you're looking at 30 to 50
million dollars being spent marketing
before the day of release there's all
those related businesses that actually
supply productions the catering
companies travel companies those that
are providing technical support
logistics post-production and so forth
not to mention the actors themselves all
those thousands of actors that are
suddenly not earning the money that they
were banking on and then obviously
there's the the effect of taxation tax
revenues for the economy at large there
is a huge ripple intake the complete
shutdown across the u.s. until July will
mean a shocking four billion dollar hit
on the box office entertainment
companies spent 121 billion to create
original content in 2019 and they were
expected to spend even more this year
but companies like Disney Netflix
Universal and others have all but shut
down during the outbreak and things
could get a lot worse the concert and
live event industry brought in thirty
four billion dollars last year three
months shut down at this time of year
could cost the industry seven billion
dollars of lost revenue if health safety
measures extend longer they'll cut into
the popular summer concert season for
Live Nation the world's biggest concert
promoter summer is when it sees 70% of
its attendance that's bad news for the
producers songwriters technicians and
over
250,000 concert employees such as
janitors security and ticket collectors
entertainment companies are moving
quickly to both alleviate these losses
and the disappointment of audiences
movies are being released on video on
demand early and some businesses are
turning to streaming in concerts online
I think we're gonna see a lot of
innovation in how the entertainment
industry operates after an events on of
this scale in the same way we're
actually going to see changes in how
consumers engage with media and the
types of media they engage the companies
that will win out in here will be the
ones that are flexible and adaptive and
the ones that are able to understand how
consumer behavior is adapting what's
driving changes in media engagement and
media consumption and what that is what
kind of opportunities that is going to
throw up as this this strange period
that we're in continues and as we return
to what may be mom'll see it may evolve
in terms of it's it's for and it's
practices but we have to keep in mind
that the entertainment industry will
recover it will come back and it will be
strong again